Yep.
Well in terms of that the early days
and we were all pioneering
types who were sort of.
You could claim credit classifies as
rugged individualists who strangely enough
wanted to live together and
share their lives together and.
One example of that was a local farmer
but we made a range went with him where
we could grow company on his land
and he would get some of
the company for his cattle
and we would use the rest of it somehow
comfrey was going to be the miracle plant
of the 70s and 80s or whatever and then.
So we got there with our company
plants already planned out
and he ploughed up the paddock so
it was loose and things like that
and we started planning and then we.
Then we realized we weren't sure how the
irrigation would work how all of this
there runoff from his
daring on ascent and water
and so on would get to each plant and
registering that paddock about 15
or more of us all a different idea
of exactly how do you think asians
and work for two hours just know
what to let go. Their particular.
Idea that how irrigation
irrigating company should work.
So i guess an idea of the sort of.
And i suppose those were the early days
in terms of us understanding how group
decisions work and all of that and
we were determined to use consensus
but we didn't have a clear
idea of the processes
that we could use to get to some
sort of decision so you know we.
Just argued in the sun for two hours and.
Until everyone got really really frustrated
i think and decided on something
or maybe the farmer came along and
sorted it out. I can't remember.
Anyway then. Oh yeah yeah. I mean we.
In the early days.
Of course because we were just beginning
in there were a lot of decisions to be
made and we didn't know
each other that well.
But but also because we were
just beginning of that meeting
and using in the same thing we met for
a full day every week. And meetings.
We did have an agenda and things like that
and gradually got the hang of
having one person to facilitate
and take the role of guiding the
meeting and so on. Whereas these days.
We meet for half a day maybe
only a few hours once a month.
And so that's just there just a
change in our need to spend time in
decision making that.
And where were you before and.
Oh yeah the changes or one
interesting thing that means saying
that the early people
were pioneer learing.
That's true of sort of the people that
came within the first four or five years
and then there was a sort of a gap
and a bunch of different sort of
people moved on after six or seven
or eight years
and these people saw a set up community
they saw water systems in the ground roads
working as they were a
community that had its rules
and structure as a way of making decisions
together set of friendships a power
system happening. Established buildings.
A whole way of life that they could
just move into great you know and
and very cheap. And just
totally inviting and so.
A different sort of
person. I'm not saying.
In any way you know in fear
or anything like that.
Lovely people and different and
and that's caused a little bit of.
Not exactly friction
but disgruntled with sometimes because the
advantage of being a pioneering person
in some ways is that you're looking around
and looking at how things are going and.
In taking initiative really being
responsible for what they're out
and really being engaged with
the land or the community.
You know whether it's a process of
us being together our relationships
or something that needs doing on the
land or a building that we might need
or whatever. Whereas the sort of second
type of people if i can call them
that i don't tend to engage
in that same way so easily.
So it's taken from me just prompting people
saying hey if you want to contribute.
How about building a visitor's house
that would be a great thing and things
that they're immediately apparent to me
just weren't apparent to them because
that all that set up and
their point of view.
Whereas my vision is still
you know running amuck.
And i imagine i'm not quite.
Well i'm not quite sure
what i meant him but
that will go it will go into some other
phases a little attract a different sort of
person again and that will bring its own.
Interesting dilemmas and compromises
and so on.
We decided in the early days part of
our idealism and more than idealism.
And that no one here could own.
Their house that they built. We don't
have shares we just have donations. And.
You can't lie claim to anything except
what you can sort of carry off in your car
more or less. And that's what
people have had to do people
that have left have left. So
you can say with nothing.
Although some have been
given money as well
but basically the non ownership of
houses is our policy which means
that we as a community may may give
some money to a departing member
or may or might not and that was.
Part of
that was idealism thinking well it wouldn't
be great to break down the structure of
land
and home ownership in australia because
it just seems to increase the gap between
rich and poor and in course
lots of trauma in society
and it seems wrong who you
know who says we can own land.
What a ridiculous notion in a way.
But it was also i think that well
that would show you were really committed
if you come into this community.
You knew in you that you
couldn't speculate on it.
In fact it was worse than you couldn't
depend on walking away with anything at all.
And so it. Meant the no
one would come here.
Other than because i really
just wanted to live with us.
Which seemed like a principal criterion
as far as i'm concerned both things the
idealism and wanting to change the world
and the practical thing of having
people who are committed but
that has meant a lot of difficulty in
recent years with for example my ex-partner
mother of my boys who more
and more grew away from the community didn't
want to participate wanted to sort of
ghostwriter whatever you'd say. And.
And her non-participation really
began to annoy other people
but how can you make someone
participate and so on.
And she started saying
well i want to leave
but i want money for the house
which we'd built together. And.
We decided that was fair enough.
And then a woman or a couple came
that really wanted to live here
and they said yeah well
that's fair enough.
We'll pay the community some money
for the privilege of living in
that already built house and
not having to build one
and the community can decide
whether pass it on to my ex
and that's what happened.
But people were very worried
about that setting a precedent
but both as far as i'm concerned
both precedents have been set.
You know people have
gone away with nothing
and gone away with something so
it leaves the power in their.
As of the community which i'm really happy
with at the moment because i think we
make decisions really well.
We do listen to each other.
Carefully and spend time when there's
an important decision to be made and.
So far of a lot of confidence in that
i'm well aware that it could go.
Could go wrong when i'm not
quite sure how at the moment.
You know. Well the legal
structure is that it be.
From out from our lawyers solicitors point
of view it would be almost impossible
persone one to take control
of the land and try
and sell it from under us we've set
up a structure that is very confusing
and very difficult to. To rort.
But then in terms of sanctioning anyones
behaviour we have no we have nothing at
all. Nothing legal at all.
Whereas for example estrada
title or something like
that does make all the rules
that a community might make up
and the start of title
get fixed in the law
and they can call in the police
to enforce it. We can't do that.
And we feel a bit strange about
having to do that actually. But.
Most. Yeah that's meant a lot to us.
Of course there's been plenty of friction
between people and misunderstandings
and hurt and anger and.
And but there's this climate in which.
Over time things get resolved
people to after the heat die down.
They're going to talk to each other and
work things through and agree to disagree
or whatever.
And i think that's that's a
function of you know values.
And just who happens to have come
here but it's also a function of a.
Between thought.
It's also a function of the
size of the group and.
So we have 20 adults here
and with about 20 children.
Which means about eight families.
A lot of sole parent families and couples.
And i think if it got up to about 30 adults
we'd find factions forming i'm fairly
wary of that self and that and that's all.
Also a great conflict because
there's a lot of lovely people.
I'd love to come
and live here people some some of whom i
feel much more affinity with than some of
the members of that.
So you know.
Yeah. Ok. Well the first thing is.
And and i made a start
but a little bit men's movement as a name
is often in question i think it's worth
questioning because it's not it's not like
a normal political movement with with a
particular agenda and are not
in a political organization or.
People joining in a marxism or
operative in parliament or something.
It's more.
And that's totally appropriate in what's
called the men's movement because.
Because while women had to find
their strength and power in society
and be able to stand up and be counted.
So to speak and be paid properly and so on
to be respected men in general had that.
What men didn't have was an
ability to be more introspective
and see life as an energy as
much as an hour to achievement.
And so a large
mass specter of the
men's movement is more.
It's in a personal growth coming down
to what i understand oneself as a man
and as a human and as a as being alive
on this wonderful planet. This time.
And so on.
So i've been involved
with working with men
and being with with men in sort of
consciousness raising groups for about eight
years. And that came out of.
Running groups for.
Called despair to empowerment groups
that were particularly focusing on one's
emotional response to the state of the
planet particularly the possibility
of nuclear war in those days.
And that came out of just
being part of green protests
and realizing that we needed
to know each other better
and to communicate better to really protest
effectively so i started working with
people and learning and training
and so on. Yep so. You know i.
Know not not in particular.
More this area not just this communities
are particularly social body farm
communities particularly socially
and environmentally oriented
and if you make a list of
all the projects people.
Members have been involved in it's
really long and quite impressive
but in terms of getting into.
Working with men.
There's one other man that
was living here at the time
and sort of a member called ken and he
and i had discussed how how women seem to
have having such a good time together in
their in their groups and the workshops
they have that are women only
and we were sort of envious and jealous
and thought can men
really have friendships
that say as close as women seem to be
and you know that's what i was asking
myself can i have comradery with with men
without having to go to war for it and
that was a real question i had no idea.
I really wanted whether it was possible.
So i think one of the first workshops we
organise which was a long weekend workshop
was called the anzac weekend.
Then the anzac within and it was
on with on the anzac day weekend.
And when which we were particularly
looking at power and authority.
So ken and i both having had
experience with designing
and running workshops we designed one
particularly for men with all sorts of
exercise that would bring these
issues up and we could discuss
and discover more about ourselves as men
and we had a bit time about
twenty five men came along
and we put them through
all sorts of exercises
and yeah.
One of the principal exercises we used in
that workshop which what we
called the circle of isolation.
And it more
or less was a reenactment just acting
out in a paddock what happens to a boy
and a male as he grows up.
So we've got first of all got some sort of
marching around militarily like you have
to do at school or you might if
you went to cadets and so on
and telling them off and so on
and then we asked them to just sort
of miller around and break into pairs
and look at each other. Look
look in each other's eyes
and imagine the other person was a childhood
friend and how you felt about that
and then break up again and
look in another man's eyes
and imagining them to be the
teacher that bossed you around
and then maybe the adolescent that
that was a bully whatever we gradually
built up a picture of the of the
different events in a in a male's life
that tend to push drive them
into isolation drive them into
having to take care of
themselves and not and
and be wary of everyone else
especially other males.
Which happens in all sorts
of overt and covert ways
and then we got everyone to get in a
circle facing outwards to sort of.
What's circle
and just start walking until you can no
longer see only just in your peripheral
vision maybe you could see another
man however very wide circle
and large paddock and ask them to feel
what that was like maybe express it
and some men were weeping and others
were just yelling and screaming
and others were just silent and
and just standing there feeling it because
they'd been in the group we'd been
sharing they walked away from it and
that just sort of mirrored for us what it's
been like growing up from feeling close
and accepted and small and
valued and being able to share
and being able to emote and so on
to being a man where you isolate
and you take care of yourself. You've got
to be in control and and you can't cry
and so on. And quite a powerful exercise
and we get men to turn around face each
other maybe make eye contact way across the
paddock and start walking in
and see what that feels like
and you know for myself although i felt
agony at being on the outside of the circle
i also felt real apprehension at coming
back in closer because they were safe out
there that's what i was used to. And.
So we did sort of coming closer
and and there was joy in that
and we we sang together
and i each other and so
but you know that's one
one exercise that i can
and i've often used in workshops since.
Just to dramatically
illustrate what happens to me
and to themselves because most
men don't even realize that.
That's happened i didn't like it's a process
of like a fish discovering what water
is.
Well that's why i can't say that's really
a movement it's just it's just a whole
lot of different men that
are quite interested in.
Well they might come out of a broken up
relationship with something realizing
that no one to talk to and their partner.
Has lots of support
or they might really think you know
i'd like to be friends with men.
Not have this sort of stand off
beer in hand relationship. And.
In terms of it. And so it's. I don't
know what to say about it in this area.
There's a lot of men most of whom you
know each other because it's only a small
group so far only be a couple of hundred.
Who are willing who really want to look at
themselves as men understand themselves
as men
and find out what it is to be a man in you
know in our generation because everything
else has been the old roles has been ripped
away from itself of being the provider
and so on and even the protector.
We can't easily be because
that involves going to war
and a kind of a without any more.
So i can no longer be a provider
or protect anything necessarily
and way back before that
the industrial revolution
and so i ripped away the ancient traditions
of what it was to be a man a past on
heritage that we've sort of more
or less lost was women's i think has
been more intact because from mother to
daughter mothers and daughters tended
to stay at home and share things with.
Men as soon as they got old enough
or out working in the factories
the apprenticeship system.
Perhaps kept up a bit of the old
traditions of what it is to be and then
but that's broken down
these days as well so.
So it's refining and also just
making up for ourselves what.
What sort of relationships
we want when each other.
Let's try them sort of
and that's been a fantastic thing to be
involved with i love nearly every moment of
it. I really enjoy it.
Of being part of all facilitating men's
groups just weekly groups where particular
thing might be used.
You know like father
either being a father or.
Father father in law or
one's own father or mother
or sex or sex and intimacy
or work or. Right. It untold number of
themes we can used as a discussion point.
And there's a lot of exercises
and things we can do together to have
fun to get to know each other better.
Come.
Yeah that's greater with a lot of suspicion
because there's rampant fear in men of
getting closer because they've been trained
not to be so they get very angry if
they see other mean doing what
they were told not to be so and
that generally quits gets called homophobia
which is you know me if i be a is a
sort of misnomer that's generally
supposed to mean fear of gay men
but i think it's really
fear of each other.
Fear fear of other men in general i mean
especially fear of any man a term that's
all. And quite happy being
uncomfortable being close
and talking about intimate things
with you and so there's that reaction
and there's all.
I personally i've had very
little almost no criticism from.
Women about what i do and i know other
men that have so i think it's. And.
I'm not sure why that is
that i'm quite. You know i.
In terms of feminism on really feel. I.
I were great debt to feminist
thinkers and all the women
that have put their lives in
their family and and so on.
On the line to make changes in our
society the sacrifices they've made and
and still i also react to some elements
of feminism where there seems to be a
bitterness against men
that i would call sort of sexist because
there's this generalized generalized
distrust which i can understand but
when i'm talking with a thinking woman
i expected her to rise above that
and but i've rarely come across that
bitterness aimed directly at me.
In what i do mostly there's
incredible support because women.
Seem to be able to see much more easily
than men can what influences are on men
from birth and also how men behave
so admirably because of them.
So i do teach men's issues in tape
sometimes in other places and.
And you know the way i like to teach this
is just actually draw out other people's
experiences
and women can talk much more easily about
what i would call men's oppression than
the men in general in the classes.
And then it can be quite a painful
topic for quite a few people to do so.
So the different the response is i think
mainly out of one's personal pain in the
area of gender. It goes back generations.
What with different genders are
sort of done to each other.
Expected to be gender.
You know. Oh. We.
We didn't ever set ourselves out to be
self-sufficient in vegetables and fruit
or whatever with that was never.
Although we called body farm where we
really more accurately call us body village
or something like that.
So that's a great relief i think it's a bit
of a mistake to put so much effort into
something for what to me is a fairly sort
of a shallow goal to be self-sufficient
not rather be integrated and i think
most people here would rather feel
that they're making a difference
to society as a whole
and therefore a part of
society rather than.
Going outside somehow and
trying to be separate. So yeah.
For myself having young twins
and getting a portrait together
of course i went on the dole
and many of us did to survive and.
I suppose a critic might say why don't you
go out get a job in the money come back
and then do. The pottery and so on
but i just was so motivated to get
this community up and running.
I didn't want to leave it for a moment. I
really wanted to be part of it every day.
And and that meant.
You know i couldn't earn money just being
there until i got the pottery up such as
me living there and being on the dole
and i got kicked off the dole more
or less for
that attitude i suppose in those days
they weren't encouraging people to set up
businesses of their own
and so really before i'd finished the pottery
buildings to my satisfaction to make
an efficient. Sort of factory.
I got kicked off and.
We went on again. That's my partner and i.
Few months later because we just had to.
You know her name.
So social security is has really been
enabled our community get to get up
and running as quickly as it
has to be very hard to to.
China and money and build this place as
well and we feel well we can justify
that in the sense that well at least
we're constructing something with
that money from the government if you
like something of lasting importance
and so now not so many people on the dole.
I think anyone maybe there was a small
business there. I had the pottery going.
I couldn't say it was very lucrative
and there was another business here
called effortless trading which we were
importing things from india and also
making up facial creams and massager well
and that that was supporting some people.
But besides that they've been no
real industries. On the community.
People have gone out to work.
And that's how it is now most people
working in lismore or the area
and teaching a whole range
of different things.
The body parts. Yeah all the body
though do you means synonymous with a.
The lightman door understanding or
the truth or something like that.
And so in our more arrogant moments we can
call ourselves farmers of enlightenment
but you know i sort of ship it or
shrink into myself saying that
but you know in some ways you could say
that you know we've we've
helped start pre-schools
and forest.
Saving organizations and. Home birthing.
Things and heart politics conferences and.
All manner of things. So
in that way in terms of.
Relative enlightenment perhaps we've
helped along the way a little bit.
You know we're what with the angle
of your question you know just
but if i'm right. You know
it's a nice clean name.
You know it's just short
term increase. And.
I think most people here
are sort of proud of it
and there is such i think is group morale
and how good you feel about the place
and which includes when you feel
about the name an image that we have
and generally we do feel good about it.
We've been criticized by the more feral.
When you say hippies in the
hills as being middle class
and to which one of our members said middle
class upper class think you know just
taking anything out of it but.
But. And that's because we.
I don't know we have had
slightly different values then.
You could say the alternative
society in general.
Because we haven't had dope on the place.
And we've been you know part of running
is meditation retreats and so on.
So sometimes we've been
criticized as being pure
and things you know ridiculous things like
that.
Yeah. Well most people here on body farm.
Are well aware of the situation in
the world where. Basically that.
The west lives on the back of third world.
And through the institution
of third world debt and
and differing prices for commodities
and people's labor and so on.
And we also well aware that there's
limited resources in the world
and not not everyone can be brought up
to a western standard with a car fridge.
You know. All the things that
we enjoy in this country.
Just the the environment groaning
bearing that it at the moment
and possibly falling apart.
Let alone as we bring all of india and
china and so on up to that standard.
So the only way in terms of that environmental
outlook on a global outlook to.
Look to for life to be sustainable on this
planet is for people to expectations in
their lifestyles to drop a bit and say
we've sort of consciously done that
but on the other side of that is
that it's just like jesus said it's easier
for a camel to hop through the eye of a
needle in the least for richmond to get
into heaven is it the truth in that is
that too many material possessions clutter
your clutter your inner life tend to
make you attached to things and
therefore it's not so easy to change
and move with way where you need to
go in on your spiritual journey. And.
So those two values sort of intermingle
with each other the global perspective in
the spiritual perspective to mean
that. And then come down to.
That there is some benefit in
having a simpler lifestyle.
Less material possessions
and less pressured lifestyle.
So i don't consider. I
consider myself pretty rich.
I been thinking about this recently
because i've been working in taste.
And just thinking about
other people's lives.
Compared to my own where i don't i don't
have very many overheads true i don't own
my house but i'm not paying
out anything on it either
and anything i build onto it
just stays there for many years
and so my wage goes a lot
further than other people's my
who are renting or paying off a mortgage
or whatever let alone running two cars
and buying the newest gadget.
So i consider myself fairly wealthy basically
because i'm pretty happy with what
i've got but but more than
that because i have instead of putting all
my work into superannuation and so on.
I put it into everything
a community around me
and my security isn't the money
so much as the people in my life.
And time will tell which
one is the better bet.
I don't know but for the
moment i much prefer this one.
Ok thank you.